all right so I'm very happy to have here
as my interlocutor Sheila Payton
longtime Milwaukee native somebody who
has left and come back which always adds
a lot of needed perspective I think to
this area in particular she is among
many other things a what we can call a
multi-genre writer so that's what I
wanted to start by talking about but I
think we're gonna range over a lot of
different topics so so Sheila you've
written I mean you've been a journalists
writing a lot of stories you you have a
book that you wrote for what would we
call them it not not just Ana lessons
but a little bit older yeah young adults
about how to make sense of life you and
I didn't know this until recently you
writes librettos so you've got a you
know tie into the music industry you've
already written and yet seen produced
one of your plays you're working at
another play that's how I got to know
you through the shut up and right I have
I left any other genres of writing out
that you I think that's about it I did
work in marketing so I did copy and ad
copy I was a freelance producer at
channel 10 36 right yeah and so I did
that but I can be done in writing I can
probably figure out how to get it done
so a lot of people are good at one kind
of writing and it just doesn't translate
into other kinds of writing why do why
do you think that's the case I think you
know well I start this way I tried to
write my first novel in grade school
okay then I went to poetry I think what
it is is that writing is my core skill
but I think journalism had a real impact
on making it possible for me to do a
variety of things and from from this
standpoint as a reporter you don't know
what story you're going to be covering
so you might be covering
a plane crash or you know some people in
the community yeah and then covering a
meeting and then covering the cat show
because you're going where the the
stories lead when the stories lead and
so the skills that I gained in
journalism I think had a major impact on
kind of my ability to go across because
sometimes you write a news story and
news stories back then were who what
when where why and how
ok and then you might turn around and do
a feature story which would be more
explanatory or might you know expose
people to to something they didn't know
for instance I did a series of stories
on a place called over town you know in
Miami which was predominantly
african-american area and it was
originally segregated it was blocked off
by a wall but it was a very lively
vibrant community where people of all
different economic levels you know lived
yeah and so it was about the way it was
the way it is now and the way people are
trying to get it back to and that that's
more of a feature story yeah that lead
into other stories up it did it did it
did we did during the 70s there was but
not specifically on that topic but
during the 70s another reporter and I
were sent out to look at the impact that
the recession was having the 70s having
people in the african-american community
the the paper was doing a story about
overall Miami but they wanted to look at
individual parts of the city also yeah
and so both of us thought well people
are probably on their last legs and
gasping for breath and what we found was
the exact opposite and then my partner
in in the series found out went to the
University and found this guy that was a
sociologist and I said why aren't these
people
in the street and he said because black
people have always had to be resilient
and and and he had studied that he
wasn't doing it
we knew I've got the data to show and so
that ended up winning a state press club
but the series ended up winning a state
Press Club award because I think in part
because it was not the traditional story
but it's what the story was
yeah so and then the other piece that
was helpful in terms of the different
styles of writing was back when I was a
reporter you ask a question you shut up
and you listened and so what that did
for me is it it taught me how people
speak and so when it comes to writing us
a dialogue the fighting sidewalk and
that kinda thing I can and then after I
left journalism I went into corporate
communication well I went to work for a
corporation Miller and I was hired
originally as a speech writer and I okay
I got them I've got them to hire me not
because I had been all these speeches
but because I gave him that pitch well
I've been listening to people talk for
five years now
so you're an Erie crossing out of one
genre into another and having that make
an argument for okay but you know one of
the things that I learned and I didn't
realize that until I actually got into
the job is it I was writing speeches for
them you know if the executives and I
would go in and I listened and one guy
speak and he sounded like a used car
salesman to me and another person sound
like a Baptist preacher another one
sounded like a professor and so when I
wrote I'm out in their rhythm and that's
a skill that I actually picked up as a
journalist that's interesting I suppose
you know I've never done any speech
writing I've done ghost writing for
authors and usually when we think about
audience you know we're thinking about
the people who are gonna be reading it
but in a way you've you've got to also
consider the the let's call them the
client or the patron as an audience as
well they don't want something that
isn't going to feel right exactly sort
of like almost like tailoring clothes
right
except your tailoring their linguistic
patterns exactly yeah so obviously being
able to write dialogue is helpful when
you if you're writing a play or even if
you're writing a novel because it's not
just novel as people talking and then
describing things yeah not as good at
describing things as I am people talking
but so you know I think this is very
interesting because I imagine some of
the people watching are you know
would-be writers who probably think that
you know there's kind of like a
hierarchy right so right you know doing
corporate communication is lower than
say writing novels just for the sake of
writing novels but and so I think a lot
of people probably figure well you know
I should learn to write poetry or I
should learn to you know write very
artistic novels and then I can easily
translate that downward but what you're
saying is in many cases you're almost
better off doing the sort of jobs so
long as you're writing you know right
what what you're doing in terms of
journalism or corporate communications
or even let's say you're writing jingles
or something it's going to teach you
more probably than like going and doing
an MFA somewhere well I don't want I
don't want to kill everybody's idea I
mean they that they shouldn't go on yeah
that's some training somewhere but I
think I think it is helpful because in a
way you almost have to be analytical
yeah I mean for instance when I went I
went from speech writing to working in
market marketing yeah corporate
communications PR and one of the things
that they did at Miller at that time was
they they were told by Philip Morris
Philip Morris obviously could not
advertise because they were a cigarette
company so they were open to any wild
and crazy idea that you but yeah you had
to show them how it appealed to the
target audience yeah I hit the bottom
line and so what that did is it helped
me to have
an analytical approach yeah to whatever
whatever it was that I was writing or
whatever it was that was doing yeah I
think there's a lot of writers out there
and I have some of them as my students
not even teaching writing who had the
view that well if they've written
something everyone ought to you know
value it because of their work and
that's just not the way I mean that's
not the way I read something if somebody
puts a book in my hands that says oh is
this is really great how do you know
it's great well it's my book well you
know I may not even read past the first
couple pages if it doesn't bring me yeah
and that's really I mean even in
journalism yeah I remember I didn't
write this line and it's one of those I
have empathy every time I say it but
there was and I can't remember where I
think it was West Virginia or someplace
like that where they had this massive
mudslide that killed a lot of people
yeah and the opening line on the news
article was they're burying a generation
today oh wow and so journalism give me
so the ability I mean even in journalism
being accurate you know and not making
stuff up you can grab people and drag
them into the story yeah so so that's
really what's important in writing in
general I mean whether you're writing a
how-to book or whether or not you're
writing a play or writing a news article
or whatever yeah it's the first the
first few paragraphs what we were taught
not with Syracuse undergrad for
journalism and what we were taught is
you find the most important piece of
information and you put it at the top
yeah and then the rest of it is sort of
filling in the blanks and explaining all
of this stuff and so if you have if you
don't you know if you say listen the
City Council met today and but if you
say the City Council passed a budget
with that raised property taxes by 20%
people will
yeah yeah I find that's you know yeah I
I read a lot of student papers and you
get a lot of hemming and hawing at the
start and the worst are the ones where
it's you know since the dawn of time
blah blah blah blah blah you know and
you're like just tell me about Plato
because that's what I asked you to
actually write about well let's talk
about your biography because I think
you've already mentioned a few points
about it you you came to Milwaukee and
and you then left came back you had a
pretty you know what we call it in some
respects a diverse career but all
centered around writing in one way or
another how did you end up leaving
Milwaukee and how did you end up in
Miami of all places so well I think
that's my junior year in high school you
know that's when you have to decide oh
yeah so I had worked for the school
newspaper and it was the I graduated in
66 so there was a lot of stuff going on
ya know during that timeframe and
basically what my brain said is I like
to write and I want to do do some kind
of writing that has a positive impact on
other people's lives yeah
and so with all the things that were
going on in the 60s in terms of the
civil rights movement and things like
that and I was watching how Journal you
know the the journalists and the media
coverage was having an impact on the
outcomes yeah well I'll be a newspaper
reporter not thinking of the fact that
there were very few people of color or
women working for major media in the
country yeah and then I you know
everybody in their uncle except my
parents try to dissuade you tried to
dissuade me girl you know they're not
gonna hire you
yeah and my parent my my parents only
comment was well we will not be alive
forever so make sure you can make money
and that was it okay and so what I did
is pretty positive
that's pretty positive and so what I did
was they brought me up to you know they
were the kind of parents with you'd
asked him a question and they'd say well
why don't you go look it up and see if
you can find the answer
oh yeah so we had got as good we had a
set of world book encyclopedias in the
house they didn't do yeah and so I said
okay what am i criteria for going to
college and I said I wanted a place with
a School of Journalism cuz I figured if
they had a whole school they'd have a
lot more stuff to offer me yeah I mean
and then I wanted a school that was not
more than ten that they had no more than
ten thousand students because I could
have gone to Missouri which was in the
excellent excellent journalism school
but it was like fifty three thousand
students and I'm thinking me and I'd get
lost in so I did my research in the
World Book Encyclopedia and Syracuse
popped up and I had no idea at the time
that it was one of the top Jake schools
in the country
and so I told my parents hey this is
where I want to go yeah and so I ended
up going out east and that was and then
the other thing is my father said you
can go to school anywhere in the world
that said Wisconsin and I went he wanted
you to get out of the state though he
wanted me to broaden my view of the
world yeah not to say he didn't want me
here but he wanted me to broaden my view
of the world yeah so Syracuse met those
three criteria and when I got there it
was again you know there was a lot of
stuff going on in campuses between 66
and 70 yeah and and so I did some
writing for the school newspaper there
and then had you know had got to meet
New Yorkers
and they got to be people from other
parts of the country in the world and it
really kind of broadened my my view of
you know what what life is like and what
the options are and what's possible do
you think will come back a little
narrative in a moment but so in
Milwaukee we were kind of fortunate in
and for a long time having and it's
still pretty good
you know the Milwaukee Sentinel as you
know an award-winning newspaper and so I
do you think like having something like
I mean we had the journal to and there
was a rivalry what do you think there
was kind of a advantage and growing up
in a place where you could actually have
a great paper in your hands I mean the
Chicago Tribune is good too and that's
just you know two hours south of here
but I don't imagine you you you were
reading the trip or anything reading
that right yeah yeah so I think that
that was very important especially
because they had to strongness me up and
they tend have different skews and they
had different skews and that was
important because the competition made
them look not only look at the same
story the same way yeah look at the
voids in the others in the other paper
in terms of what was being covered and
so that was that was phenomenal I ended
up interning at the Journal Sentinel one
summer oh yeah while you were at
Syracuse while I was at Syracuse that
must have been very interesting that he
could compare what you were learning in
journalism school with how things
actually were happening on the ground
as what was that like uh it was
interesting with what the one thing that
I learned what I got to Syracuse which
was really awesome was that most of the
professor's there have been working
journalists oh so they not only were
able to say theoretically back they
would say this is how you do this and
this is how you do that on deadlines
yeah yeah I imagine they probably didn't
give a lot of extensions for no let's
introduce if that means that you had
both theoretical and sort of the craft
knowledge getting integrated at the same
time and that was the only thing that I
think I could say that I didn't learn
how to do at Syracuse was to dictate
from my notebook on deadlines I mean
they didn't they didn't rehearse us on
that and the first time I had to do that
I thought it was I was gonna die the
other ends of the county yeah
covering something and it needs to hit
the paper the first edition of the paper
and I went into the phone booth and I
call in and say hey this is what
happened they say okay we'll put you up
connect you with the rewrite guy and
just dictate the story to him and I went
Wow because I knew has damaged sort of
all arranged up in here yeah but again
that was a skill that I learned you know
so I'm sitting there my in the phone
booth like that and flipping through the
pages and figuring out what's what
yeah and then and but fortunately I got
a really good rewrite black guy is you'd
say okay till we know what's the most
important thing that happened so I think
he would write it and then I'd say okay
now we're there any quotes associated
with that I mean so he was kind of gone
through the process so that was that was
helpful but you asked me how I ended up
in Miami I had another internship at the
Rochester Democrat and chronicle which
is you know Rochester it's mainly
Buffalo Syracuse Rochester or something
like that yeah so they're all learning
like the river and the lakes yes it's
kind of like
he was in Kenosha yeah you're right it
is and so the guy that was the managing
editor at the Rochester Democrat and
chronicle got the job offer in Miami at
the end of my internship or two at the
end of my internship he said hey you
know moving down to Miami would you'd
like to have a job I was twenty and they
said well you know I am planning to go
to grad school I've been accepted the
neurons weren't firing oh yeah and he
said oh well how long is your program
and I said well I'll be out next August
he said we'll give me your phone number
and so I must have done something well
because in July he called and said would
you like to come work and I went okay
and so that's how I ended up at Miami
and that's very unusual because normally
when you start out and it went back in
that day if you start out a newspaper
journalist you go to somewhere in the
middle of the cup you know the country
or somewhere in a small town yeah you
know basically shallow city to a major
city and not only that to go from right
out of college to with him from one of
the top ten papers in the country was
like unheard of yeah but again the
timing was right because because of the
things that were going on in urban
centers around the country
newspapers were looking to hire people
of color and women to cover them you
know to kind of bring a different
understanding yeah to the newsroom so
you know so I think a lot of people view
that the advantages would be people
looking at from the outside can see kind
of a Benetton color you know sort of
thing but I think and there's also the
view like well you know everybody's got
their background in perspective you know
I myself have found that backgrounds
overlap an awful lot
there's a lot of differentiation within
it but it seems like one of the
advantages would be being able to get
sources to talk to you you haven't
talked with other people yep
and also that Plus also picking up on
the cultural cues oh yeah you know yeah
so someone may know what questions to
ask to what questions to ask someone may
see a situation and recognize an example
that I use and this is not and it
applies to things beyond this yeah is if
I see a group of young men walking down
the street which Goods on
yes agging I can tell the difference
between those I need to watch and those
I mean they're not afraid of you know
cuz they're just walking around being
fashionable yeah or you know I can know
how to approach someone let's say the
older person mm-hmm that may be reticent
to you know talk because you know took
off the record to go on the record or
you know I'd say from my grandparents
generation back it wasn't really it
could be dangerous for you to tell
people too much about yourself yeah you
know that kind of thing and so make them
comfortable enough to be willing to
share some things and not necessarily
bad things or terrible things or
anything like that but just you know
open up a little bit you know to to
answer the questions yeah and so the way
you approach them you don't come in and
say what's up you know doing that it's
like oh really you know okay so you know
what you think about that yeah that kind
of approach giving them the opportunity
to to say what they want to say right
yeah and then pausing you know like I
said you asked the question is rather
than a stylus yeah yeah so that that's
actually that's kind of a good lead-in
to talking about your dramatic work you
mentioned the need to listen and hear
you mentioned the need for almost like
timing
all right and you know in order to so
you you've written to well you're the
process of finishing your second play
you've written one play plays are
essentially dialogue with a few stage
directions and what makes them work is
somebody just like with it with music
you know you can have the notes they're
abused they don't phrase them how do you
get that across to I mean when you it's
sort of like you've got your baby there
how do you put your baby into the hands
of somebody who's actually going to have
the right phrasing how can you tell that
well I was fortunate in that the the
subject matter of my play happened to
sync up with assist with
sesquicentennial of the Civil War
oh that's right yeah yeah and so I had
sent my play to a theatre company in st.
Louis and had heard anything from them
but you know and I've been all of a
sudden I got a call from them saying hey
we're interested in doing your play and
I went oh how much advance notice that
you have well it was pretty good I mean
I caught me in the like maybe the late
summer and they in the play was actually
gonna be produced in November so so we
had a little it's only a few months it's
only a few months but it was that mean
the play was done yeah so the it turned
out that the theatre company had
partnered with the Historical Society
and they were doing this as programming
around the successful Centennial and so
the guy from the Historical Society said
wow I really wish I you know I had a
play about free women of color prior to
the Civil War and theater person that's
pretty specific I know I know
and here the guy went I think I know
somebody hold on a second okay Wow and
that's what and that's really what those
are the characters in my play okay
free women of color and in the short
version of the
story is these women are having their
book club meeting they call them
literary societies back then and during
the course of the play they discover a
stowaway at the house and they have to
make a decision whether or not to help
the person escape to freedom and the
challenge you know in today's world
would be of course of course we do this
but back then had they been caught they
their families we've been sold into
slavery so that's kind of the I think I
mean you could say that there could be
parallels today to like well you've got
somebody who's who's an undocumented
immigrants and you know that Isis is
looking for them you and your family
background maybe it's not something
having to do with I don't know
immigration but there's something that
you don't want people to look into
exactly yeah exactly exactly and so we
we actually did a production I mean I
ended up working with the director yeah
I went down for the very beginning of
the rehearsals and then I would came
down and I came you know prepared to
make edits as necessary and then I came
in the toward the middle of the
rehearsal and development stage and we
had conversations basically it went you
know she was directing it yeah there
were little nuances like she said well
why don't we have some so-and-so come in
and she'll pick up something and eat it
and walk around the room I said okay
these are Victorian ladies they will not
they will not touch a feed piece of food
without praying over at first yeah and
she went you're absolutely right you
know so but but what there weren't that
many different things like that but
there are a couple of times where I just
kind of you know said okay now we got it
bring what I want to do is bring me off
then accessibility yeah there versus
what we would do yeah and and then I
came out via Slee for opening night so
that's actually I want to come back to
this but that's a good sort of topic as
well when you're talking about the
authentic sensibility you're talking
about things
in the past where are our morals have
changed and I'm not talking about like
you know big picture things I'm talking
about the you know like he's you
mentioned how how people would actually
eat how they would comport themselves
how do we recapture that I know for you
it happens through research because I
see every day every time that we're
meeting for shut up and right you have
your books a lot how do you translate
that into you might say almost being
like you know you get it once one foot
here solidly in the 21st century and
you've got another foot back in the
nineteenth century as sort of I don't
know a translator how do you do that
well that's where journalism came in
again oh interrupts yeah because you
know part of what you would do is
research yeah and you know you know as I
said you never knew what story you would
be covering and so if you're going to a
cat show you not to do a lot of research
but if you could go and interview
somebody there was some I forgotten who
he was he was like the secretary of HUD
or something like that wasn't down for
something and I needed I had no clue
about the topic so I did some quick
research to at least be able to answer
question I asked questions it sounds a
reasonably intelligent yeah and then
when I got through that he said you know
that's the most thorough interview I've
ever had so research was part whether
the skills bank and quick research so
what I did for instance with the play
was I said okay you know I know the big
picture thing about the Civil War era
yeah but I don't know the fine points so
I said okay what were people eating what
were they reading what their clothes
look like what music were they listening
to yeah what were the issues that were
going on
you know that habits how did you find
that that out I mean did you go back to
a lot of newspapers and and reviews and
things like that from the time I did
research me on the Internet yeah but but
I did it by you know you google things
like okay well let me start going down
rabbit holes and Oh rabbit hole
then you come back up for but but but I
started doing those things you know
trying to trying to really understand
and what I found out the way the reason
I said it in Baltimore is what I found
out was that Baltimore Maryland yeah was
it was a slave state Baltimore was like
Madison Wisconsin the hippie-dippie
place Oh in terms of race relations yeah
yeah for their time don't get carried
away it wasn't all kumbaya yeah but but
it was that and I thought well that's
more interesting than setting to me then
setting it in Mississippi or Alabama
that was like yeah hunkered down yeah so
that's one thing so I said okay I want
to do that and then I also said okay
what what interesting things I mean I
woke up and literally woke up in the
middle of the night one night was 1859
in my brain don't ask me why but that's
why you said yeah because I wanted to
send it close to the Civil War time but
before the Civil War yeah and and I said
okay so now let me go see what was going
on in 1859 and I found out Harpers Ferry
happened in 1850 yeah and I thought oh
okay Oh
Harpers Ferry is to Baltimore oh oh
they're like 50 or 60 miles late
yeah oh that's interesting and then I
ran up on Harpers Ferry and when did I
find out that Beach
John Brown and his folks stopped a train
that was Arlen's way to Baltimore and
held it for a while
and the way that people found out about
Harpers Ferry is that for some reason
they decided to release the train and
let it go all the way to Baltimore and I
thought yes so I look for those little
pieces like that yeah generally when I
start writing if it's fiction I know the
beginning and
I have a sense of the beginning and I
have and I know what the end is or have
a sense of the end and so all I need to
do then is to fill in the stuff in the
middle of a party
yeah 500 miles long from beginning you
can amp out the way some authors do you
know you've got your your end points
then you actually map like we'd each
character is doing it at one point or
something like a storyboard no actually
I never give this as a journalism teeth
yeah what I did was I I had like piles
of research and so what I did after I
got my piles of research was I went
through and I read everything and I'm
highlighted in different colors you know
this oh this would make some this might
be a good yeah point or this might be
you know a an interesting scene you know
whatever and I highlighted it in
different colors and so as I was writing
I'd say oh I need to have something
happen here I knew that was highlighted
in blue let's not go through my pages
and figure out what would make sense in
the context of you know imagine you must
have had at least ten times more stuff
than what actually went into it
absolutely one of the difficult things
for writers often is cutting I imagine
the journalism part probably helped with
that oh yeah right oh yes you know
everything has to be very trim right
whereas a novel make it as sprawling as
you like yeah it didn't happen all the
time but sometimes you know they say you
got a page and I have to say it and I've
just done you know and I've discovered
City Danny budget it was like okay let
me figure out which is the most
important stuff but people did you ever
feel bad about the material that was
orphaned in that way you know did you
feel like you'd somehow missed out by
this part not being publisher were you
okay with that
you know it's okay because because the
purpose you know I I knew what the
purpose is not the purpose but I knew
trying to do it in the plane yeah I knew
it I was trying to do now there were
other interesting things in there but
one of the things that journalism
teaches you to do is to say yeah that's
interesting but does it move it forward
doesn't make the story forward yeah and
so so that was that was helpful to me
and the other thing is I haven't thrown
that information away you know it could
be used somewhere else and and actually
the way that I found the book that the
women were reading you know when at the
beginning of the play was I said okay so
what was the literature during that time
yeah a tale of two cities opening line
it was the best of times it was the
worst of times that was exactly what was
going on in the women's lies because
they as I said you know the the
Baltimore was relatively liberal yeah
but as as the country moved closer and
closer to Civil War some of the freedoms
that they had enjoyed were being paired
away and attitudes toward them were
changing as a result of the tension over
the you know the war that was brewing
right yeah and so I said well that's got
to be the book that they're reading and
so I just you know had to read the first
paragraph and then start talking about
it and then not talking about it only in
terms of the literature but in also in
terms of what's going on in their lives
and you you you probably have never been
to a woman's book club but that happens
a lot you know we talk about the book
and we talk about what's going down in
the world yeah I you know I've been in a
lot of book clubs but they've always
been you know mixed so to speak I think
the the stereotype of women's book clubs
of course is that they're you know
they're they're excuses for women to get
together and why they really started a
very different purpose oh and the other
thing that I found out that made me
excited about doing this story was I
found out that some of the litter
societies that give through Oh more a
part of the underground yeah remember
you're telling me about that yeah and
when I found that out I said if that's
not drama I don't know what it is
yeah so you found that out after you'd
already started no no I found that out
of my research okay yeah so I researched
until I felt like okay I've got enough
to work with here and then there were a
couple of times as I was writing that I
needed to do some additional research to
kind of you know make things move
logically to the next point and I'm
generally speaking I had done research
prior to that so your playwriting comes
out of the process of research and
almost like a fermentation you could say
of all these different facts and
entangled ideas and how do you then and
this is something we were talking about
before how did you decide make your
characters are gonna be like because you
can have a great set of ideas and if you
don't have characters to move the story
along that are compelling that people
can tie in with you're just basically
getting a service so first of all I
figured you know you can't have a book
club with two people so I knew it had to
be about five people might be good oh
yeah and then I said okay now who are
these people
and if you think about Victorian ladies
you think about Ron Dobbs yeah okay
so we had to I wanted to have a grand
table then I found out that there were
people who have been people who were
freed people who had gone on to live
better lives
yeah and so I said okay I want one of
those personalities in there but in the
play it's not known until a very
important point in the plane that she
had ever been enslaved okay you know so
that's one of those things where it's
like oh and then I wanted you know kind
of a firebrand kind of person yeah okay
you know it's like a rabble rabble
rouser
and then I wanted I found out that there
was an Amy Church in the in the you know
that would make sense you know yeah that
was very much involved in the
anti-slavery movement yeah so I had to
pass to his wife in there and then I
thought okay now let's get somebody a
little bit younger in there I mean these
women are all in their thirties
let's give somebody a little bit younger
and they're this you know just starting
to you know get a feet under and have
her be the you know the future
representing kind of the future and
facing you know learning from these
women how to be a good Victorian a woman
she's single but learning how to be a
good Victorian woman but at the same
time facing a future there's not as
secure as the one that they had had most
of their lives does she have to figure
out them like what she can learn from
them is probably still going to be
usable you know 10 20 years well down
the line
her concern is more will I be had the
same opportunity to do first of all the
younger woman is the daughter of a
friend of the woman having the yeah and
so it's not like she just popped in and
said hey can I join you but but she had
reached an age where you know marau n--
there would be good for her grooming and
upbringing as a Victorian lady kind of
thing and maybe your mother incurred
maybe your mother talked to around
hadn't thought that far but maybe your
mother said would you mind if my
daughter came to you but you know that
kind of thing sure so but her she was
she was not necessarily there as a
student you know she was trying to I
mean consciously as a student yeah it's
part of her formation it's part of her
firm information right and and but
because she's growing up into
times I mean it's kind of one of the
things that I thought about this this
weekend when the young people were oh
yeah that was awesome
did you know so though I went I had work
at the corner I didn't know that it was
happening I just like heard the
helicopters overhead so I was like
something must be going on the and II
looked it up and I saw that they were
having the rally so I popped over there
and the entire Courthouse Square was
totally filled that's what's going over
into the other areas and then you look
at the DC kind of gratifying yes I
cheered that but one of the things that
I remember them saying in some of the
interviews prior to the the March in DC
was that we are the members of the
Columbine generation and I went you know
how and so that's the kind of person
that she was that she she's sitting
there thinking you know they had
wonderful lives and look at how you know
smooth things have gone for them yeah
and I'm a single person you know I want
to live the same kind of life but I
don't know if I'll be able to because
the way things are changing around me
yeah and so that was so that's kind of
how what her conversation was what her
comments were that's her motivation her
motivation is you know you know how do i
how do i I call it living in a bubble
you know because the ladies had been
living in a bubble
pretty much compared to everybody else
but she was concerned that she would
have a bubble to live there that she
wanted to to to have that lifestyle not
for any selfish reason but just that's
what she had grown up in and she just
to continue it interesting and so those
so when I had it so what I did was I you
know put down the name and the age of
the person and and then I actually wrote
maybe a quarter to half page Bible I'm
just one of them and then that way kind
of helped me focus on who they were and
how they might talk and how they might
talk in that kind of thing
yeah does it help you figure out I
imagine there's some conflicts within
the play as there aren't any successful
those doing that give you an idea like
who should wind up in conflict or
are you when you write are you the kind
of writer who finds their characters
doing things and then a surprise play I
think in my mind they're pretty
developed yeah but for instance with the
woman who had been enslaved and they
didn't know it yeah she was not I didn't
know which something she's the one that
kind of went hey how about this idea
and so that I hadn't thought through
it's just like I knew that she was gonna
be there but I didn't know what her role
would be I knew what the firebrands role
would be and it was a young woman's role
would be I know it the Diamonds rule
would be I knew what the and so I knew
everybody what every characters role
would be but not this one and then all
of a sudden it occurred to me that she
would be the bridge between the person
trying to escape
and these Victorian women that were
multi-year multi-generational
yeah free you know yeah so so that's how
I came up with her role in the
the plate okay tell us a little bit
about your your new play that you're
working on well the one I'm working on
now is it's always intrigued to me how
people can you know human beings can not
like each other I mean not let's let's
be real
yeah hate each other yeah for no
apparent good reason
yeah and so what I'm trying to do now
and probably I don't know exactly when
it's going to be said it's either going
to be in the sixteen hundreds of the
1807 figured out yet but what I'm trying
to do is kind of look at the origins of
racism yeah and and I wanted to be in
play where it's not punch in the face
punch in the face punch in the face
I want the play to be it's gonna be a
smaller cast probably okay but you know
characters who are they're both
indentured but what has happens to be
half in America and what happens to be
European okay and and they and they're
getting along fine and you know but
they're at that pivot point where things
start to change and you see their
relationships start to change so this is
taking place over a number of years then
probably yeah yeah or maybe or maybe
yeah it would because maybe acts yeah it
would because act act one would probably
need to be kind of more at the beginning
of their relationship and that kind of
stuff and then in act two you see the
shifting in use and you begin to realize
what the shifting is about and it's not
about them as people but it's more
outside pressures that you know kind of
impact their relationship and and then
it's a very I haven't figured out
exactly what yet but there's a very
subtle thing shift that happens it's not
one of these again punch in the face
kind of sounds but it's very subtle
shift that happens that makes you vote
dang yeah so that's kind of that are
pathetically they could both survive
seasoning together
the beginning which killed off so many
indentured servants in the Carolinas and
Virginia do you think about how how
terrible summers are we heard our
imagined it without any amenities well I
you know before we run out of time
because I know I want to be conscious
let's talk about some of the props that
you wish would you have to do with
writing so you've got this what
essentially you have a book for
teenagers right so this could be
something for college students yeah in
Cass's lee and it's it's a set of short
essays you know very sort of
down-to-earth titles and and they're you
know they're several pages each you know
I got to read through the one on anger
and hatred that you've got here and what
was what what got you thinking that you
wanted to write it's not a self-help
book as such it's more like here's
here's how to figure things out right
right you don't have a system my oldest
niece was living in another state and
she was about to become a teenager okay
and you know and I wanted to share my
most of the genre letters to a young
exactly yeah and I didn't want to you
know if I talked to her on the phone I
wanted to stay away the way you do this
and you do you know I didn't want to do
that so so I said okay what letters -
yeah as a matter fact the working title
was letters to my niece
and so I thought about all of the
different experiences I had yeah and and
then all of and how I had you know
navigated the waters and
but then I also thought about examples
from other people's lives there's an
essay in here that talks about the
Olympics and I don't forgot exactly when
and where there was but it's mentioned
in the book but there was a runner who
was doing a marathon and he had he was
way past meddling I mean everybody else
had gone in and it was he had to be and
he and he had you know everybody else
had gone in and he was still running to
finish the race yeah and people would
people realized and the stands realized
that they stood up and cheered for him
until he crossed the finish line and
that's really how I came up with the
title of what comes closest how you feel
because he had it set a goal for himself
yeah obviously his initial goal may have
been to win a medal but the bottom line
was he wasn't going to do that but he
had set a goal to represent this country
and finish the race and and so I use
examples like that in addition to it and
what I do is I have the essays under
different headings so you know being you
dealing with people overcoming obstacles
so that it's almost a reference book
because when you're in that age run the
likelihood of you reading a 200 page
book somewhere between things that you
can picture a young person really I mean
in a way they're the sort of things that
they might not want to ask somebody but
now I think a lot of them would go on
the internet and Google the stuff but
you know you know
this this strikes me is a sort of thing
I would want to I would want my kids to
have and I actually did Road tested
before I published it because how did
you do that well I asked somebody that I
knew the principal in high school oh no
I said would you you know is it possible
for me to maybe get some of the kids to
read some portions of the book and give
me some feedback yeah and she said and I
explained it to her and I send her some
you know some of the pieces so yeah let
me talk to the English teacher he took
it as a the whole and took it as a
because it was teaching critical
thinking oh and so he took it as a text
for them to do critical thinking okay
and so they so they had different
segments I think I came in like maybe 20
or 30 pages each so you know so they
wouldn't their brains wouldn't fry and
then I came in and they gave me feedback
on it you know because I wanted to make
sure that whatever I said didn't just
make sense to me yeah and you know and
then the feedback was helpful and then I
also knew someone who worked for the
North Central why and I did some focus
groups there okay and so the idea was
again to make sure that it made sense to
the audience and not just to Sheila's
Alicia yes I have a book did you have
any sections or essays then that either
you got rid of or you revised very
heavily yeah and and it's been a while
so they don't remember but I do remember
making some revisions because one of the
things again thinking about language and
what makes sense I mean if I make a
literary allusion to something that
nobody has any but that yeah yeah I've
just lost him
so so I've made sure what I wanted to do
is to make sure that my language was
correct and I
was one one essay where they kept saying
I have no idea what that means
okay let's go back and then I asked
questions to get an understanding of
where the barrier you know where the
wall was
yeah and then we went back and rewrote
rewrote it so that it made more sense
you know I remember some of my
colleagues in philosophy getting
irritated over the fact that they could
no longer use they're no longer comma
they still kept using them
Star Trek metaphors you know to the new
generation I think was sort of the last
cultural touchstone there were a few
other Star Trek shows after that but
they were they were you know students
they kept on wanting to like talk about
for example you know in terms of
rationality mr. Spock well that's like
you know 30 40 years ago but they kept
on pushing and pushing you do the
opposite which is to think that there's
some merit actually and again that's you
know that's the journalism and marketing
you know coming together because I could
have the world's greatest whatever yeah
but if you don't eat in the window thing
if you don't see what's in it for you
why are you gonna why would you bother
to take your time or spend your money
yeah that's true
let's talk about another genre and it's
not quite in 70 exactly writings more
editing and say right the black pages
okay and I don't think that most people
in the audience will install what this
is so it's like the yellow pages but but
it's it's different why don't you tell
us first what it is and then why did you
why did you start this project okay I
had one site Miller I started my work
yeah and there was a woman who actually
started the publication in Milwaukee and
she actually it's national or it was
nationally oh I don't know it was
initially started in Atlanta Georgia oh
and then there were black pages
independently owned black pages and
communities around the country and the
intent was to encourage people to buy
from black owned businesses and
businesses and support you know
development things in the community
because you know we live in a capitalist
society and vote with your pocketbook
sort of idea was your pocketbook kind of
thing and you know the more times the
dollar circulates within the community
the bigger the impact it has and so it
helps communities become more
self-sufficient and not relying on
outside resources to you know make
things work yeah so so I was an
appetizer in her directory and then she
decided she wanted to run off and get a
harley-davidson dealership or she was
offered one and so she she got one and
and I said oh well what are you gonna do
with your directory I don't know I think
it's I have to sell it and because it
fit with what I was doing which was to
try to help businesses yeah in my
marketing business try to help
businesses to promote their business
excuse me
and so I bought it and with each
addition I promote so we've got the
black pages here this is the Wisconsin
black pages why don't you tell us what
this is how you got involved with it and
white why do you think it's it's
important okay
well the black pages franchise if you
want to call it that is
really something that started in Atlanta
years ago where somebody decided that
they wanted to promote the idea of
buying goods and services from
businesses owned by African Americans
and then it kind of spread across the
country and people basically started you
know doing the same thing and I at the
time I had a small marketing business
and the person who actually got the
franchise in Milwaukee it's not really a
franchise it's almost like an
independent business okay but but you
but you do have the rights to use the
term black pages but she approached me
about advertising and she explained what
the purpose was and I thought oh short
of fine I'd love to be in there and then
she had an opportunity to get a
harley-davidson dealership which is a
big thing here in Milwaukee and and she
decided that she was going to get out of
the business and I said oh so who's
gonna buy what are you gonna do with
your publication she said well I'm gonna
sell it so I bought it from her because
it fit in with what I was trying to do
which is to help small businesses to get
some air time yeah and one of the
reasons why that's important is that the
more times dollars circulate within a
community the stronger that community is
because you know if I'm building a
business and I hire the people who put
up the building and I hire people who
for security as security guards yeah and
I buy a supplier the people who clean
the building yeah and I hire people who
maybe have food store and I buy from
them then that helps those businesses
grow so that they can hire more people
and so I've been doing this since about
1999 and one of the things that I have
always focused in
is the economic benefits of doing that
what am I not this particular book
directory but one of my earlier
directories I found out that it was like
2.2 about two billion dollars touch the
hands of African Americans in the City
of Milwaukee either here purview yeah
and I went whoa you know and we're not
talking just you know people in a
certain neighborhood yeah
and so my essay was about if you know
the I think the the the ratio was two to
one so if it's if the dollars circulated
you know twice in the community that
that would have an impact of this yeah
in this particular director of book I
call the books what is a directory my
essay is about something that I had
didn't know anything about apparently
there was a study that was done by a
university professor and she found out
that the more african-american owned
businesses you have in a community yeah
the the lower the violence level is in
that community what makes sense and and
it was I went oh my gosh yeah and so the
essay was about the fact that it's not
just about buying from somebody yeah
about you know helping the community to
become you know more cohesive I mean a
business would include not just hiring
but also sponsorship of institutions
like mentoring right and showing kids
that there's a plan b c d e and f other
than so was something we were talking
about earlier this is you know one of
the most segregated large cities in the
united states and yet you know when we
meet downtown you'd never guess that is
this more important in a
city like Milwaukee then say I don't
know
I mean Chicago is pretty segregated as
well but it's not as segregated as
Milwaukee is it's not as it may be
segregated but it also is more
economically diverse yeah
then they Milwaukee in communities of
color and so I think it's very important
because I live on you know in Cold
Spring Park area and it's a neighborhood
kind of it's like five minutes literally
five minutes drive from from downtown
Milwaukee and it's an area that's kind
of in transition yeah
and so I see people you know during the
day walking up and down the streets that
have no jobs I see you know people who I
mean they're homeowners there obviously
but I see you know young people who look
like they've got the weight of the world
on their shoulders and you know they're
going to kick me they're going to great
school and I'm like really
yeah and so one of the things that is
important is not only the job creation
piece but seeing somebody else who is
doing okay and and giving them the
belief that that could happen that
happened to me um you know my my block
years ago where this woman was living in
within the rental properties and she I
mean I was getting ready Drive off and
she came over to my car and I saw you
know either corner of my eye I saw this
face up against my windshield yeah I
mean my window and I was like okay what
was this and I look around and she drank
a lot you know so I kind of cracked the
window what I said hi how you doing and
she said okay you know and then she said
you know what I see you go into work
every day and I think I'm I trying to
get myself together oh wow
and I was like whoa I didn't even know
she was paying attention to me yeah I
mean I used to wave it or as I laugh
but yeah so it's those kinds of things
you know this is an adult so think about
what what it could mean to kids to see
somebody that's not an athlete an
entertainer or a criminal yeah you know
which is are the three primary areas
that everybody knows they can do you
know and I'm not saying that that's it I
grew up in Milwaukee Wynn was literally
segregated I mean they with the red
lining stuff mmm
and you worried allow you know it's
supposed to be I I never crossed the
viaduct to the south side in my entire
life until probably after I came back to
Milwaukee and it was a few years before
that I I felt comfortable doing that
because it was you know could be
hazardous to your health
yeah but in on our block my both my
parents of college graduates we had
people who were working in blue-collar
jobs working in you know industry at the
time when it was you know you could
provide a pretty viable I think we have
one family that was on welfare we had a
jazz musician who lived on the block you
know so kids had a variety of models to
look at and say oh I think maybe that
one over there but now I think part of
the issue is that it's the segregation
is not only racial but its economic yeah
very much and so it's harder for them to
see beyond the three options yeah that
are you know that they can see on TV and
so that to me is why this is more
important is it's not so much I am
making no money on this I call this my
charity project yeah well you're
investing a lot of time to and I'm
investing time yeah but but I think it's
important because it not only promotes
the idea of entrepreneurship and it not
only promotes the idea of supporting
businesses but like I said the essay he
talks about the the impact in this
particular book each in each book I put
information in
above the other zip codes and things
like that I think would be helpful for
people to know this particular book I
have all the information you need to
know about being able to vote oh you
know and I did that intentionally yeah
because I knew that you know we were
going to have some major elections
coming up this year yeah and it's not
saying vote for anybody here's the
process here's what you do here's where
you go here's contact information here's
phone number you know you know that kind
of thing so that's part that's part of
my public service you know to the to the
community and I see this as both maybe
meeting those two purposes economic
improvement as well as it's helping
people understand that they can't move
past well then I think that's very
important in one way it connects with
like a long tradition of cultivating
self-reliance right and development
through economic means rather than just
trying to you know let's you know
seize political power or something like
that economics is something that the
Hamptons day-in day-out you know I'm
also reminded when I when I taught at
Fayetteville State University one of the
big problems we had in Fayetteville
State is a historically black college
seventy percent african-american
students and we had a hell of a time
holding on to young black male students
and one of the issues was that that sort
of well I don't want to be I don't want
to show myself is too smart because if I
do that I'll get ridiculed I won't be
you know viewed as a elephant eclis
black exactly yeah and I think you
probably see something similar with well
oh you're gonna be a business owner you
know but it seems very important because
those are the things that allow people
genuine freedom and give them some I
mean other issues is having equity you
know most people the equity in that they
have is in in whatever home they they
happen to be paying the mortgage if
there is that but the business ownership
allows a different kind
equity and opens up a lot of other doors
is a growing year after year what the
book yeah you know it pretty much stays
the same size although I'm keep coming
trying to come up with ideas to kind of
you know yeah get him you get it to grow
the it's interesting talking about
Milwaukee being a different place there
was a woman who had a book in Rockford
Illinois yeah and it was about that's a
city that's a rough condition
I've been down there yeah but her book
was about like that Wow and I you know
and we're much smaller than they're much
smaller than Milwaukee and at the time
you know we we used to have black pages
conferences and no around you know we
convened in the city but anyway so I saw
her book and I said how is it that your
booty looks like that - mine looks like
this and she said Milwaukee is a very
tough market because look people's minds
are have been you know kind of caged and
they're thinking a difference is there
gonna be sort of despair despair or or
the opposite or not the opposite but
also jealousy I mean I had a person I
had somebody helping me with some sales
one year and there was an organization
that was in the health care area that
was working very hard to you know but
that's when they were just starting to
discover the health care yeah yeah and
they were working to try to close the
gap and so I offered she offered them
the opportunity to be in the black pages
and the response she got was I saw
Sheila at a Bucks game she doesn't need
the money and I'm like so I'm here to
help you yeah yeah she've your goal and
what if you saw me at the Bucks game
that meant that you were there - yeah
help me out here so those those two
things are you know kind of make it more
difficult yeah and part of it is you
know it's not just you know that people
just hate each other or you know do
things
when I grew up the place where farmed
like the the the 145 spur drops off yeah
that was the heart of the black business
district okay that's where they decided
the City of Milwaukee and His infinite
wisdom decided to put the this spur that
drops off on Fonda life yeah and they
said they were going to connect it to
the rest of the expressway and this is
back in the 60s the rest of the
expressway so you have this big loop
covering the city it never connected
yeah they did is they destroyed the
heart of the black business district in
Milwaukee so yeah you know so you know
it so it's you know there are a lot of
factors that have come into play but the
bottom line is and I keep saying this to
folks and they keep looking if without
all of them some of them agree but some
people look at me like and what planet
are you from my father was a marine and
he also grew up in the south you know
both my parents grew up in the south and
they always told me the best way to find
a helping hand is at the end of your own
arm not meaning that you don't ask for
help not meaning that you don't accept
help
yeah but don't assume the count count so
the cavalry is on their way and and I
think and that we also had what we
called the village which is the adults
who said all of these are our children
and we're going to make sure they're
going to be okay and that that has that
declined an intergenerational security
that almost exactly uh and part of that
my father was a social worker initially
and then he went into juvenile justice
he was a probation officer information
supervisor children's court while he was
a social worker and I'll be real quick
while he was a social worker they
started the powers-that-be started
instituting rules that made it more
difficult to keep families together one
of them was no man in the house even if
the man was the married father of the
children because otherwise they the
family would not be eligible for welfare
and and he started out stabilizing
people on welfare and then helping the
new who back out in the market in the
juvenile justice system when my father
died one of the people that spoke at his
funeral said mr. Payton used to be my
Pio and I'm looking I'd known him for
years and I'm like wow yeah and then he
explained that he you know done stupid
stuff as a kid yeah but that he had been
able to help him understand the error of
his ways and help him to see the
possibilities you know for his future
yeah and the punchline was and today I'm
an adult probation officer some of the
things my father was able to do as a
probation officer and supervisor I give
the powers-that-be start instituting
rules at preventing them for doing that
so so there are a lot of factors that
come into play you know that make it
more difficult for for things to happen
but still we we need to try to encourage
people to say we're here
we got a block we're controlling the
block and we're gonna make it work yeah
so I mean you see prospects for for
doing that within the Milwaukee
community as it currently exists I think
there's I I think it can be done and I
think I think the churches can play a
role in that I mean I yeah churches are
doing a good job of you know taking care
of people and feeding them and that kind
of thing but I think also if they could
help them to understand how the system
works and how the worthless system yeah
to their benefit and work with them in
terms of doing that and then maybe get
them to basically say this is our turf
we got a block and this is ours yeah and
then have them you know to reinstitute
the village one block at a time I mean
everybody wants to make Milwaukee great
and it's such a big place and there's so
many things that need to be done that
going for the whole city is like trying
to eat an elephant and once
but if you get yourself even the whole
neighborhood live in a whole
neighborhood yeah but if you but if you
do it one block at a time there's a
possibility that you can get that block
done and then you move to the next block
and let the first block know we're still
here yeah I mean you know how we're
still good to help and then you get
enough blocks together to create a
neighborhood association and now you got
some girl and where the people are
engaged in their own liberation you know
I read something recently that Milwaukee
has an extraordinarily high number of
neighborhood associations somehow we're
like way beyond the national I think
we've got to be the Los Angeles I think
we're like almost at the level of them
and it's a part because there are so
many neighborhoods in Milwaukee that do
have some sort of neighborhood
consciousness and then there's something
about I don't remember exactly the
specifics something about the tax
structure as well but it encourages I
think those are very useful
organizations for doing that that kind
of work you know is one of the one of
the challenges like with businesses is
if if they become you know successful
enough and start scaling up then they
let you lay well let's take Miller right
I mean you worked at Miller Miller isn't
Miller anymore it's sa B and it's not
really a Milwaukee business although
they have a nice Park here and stuff
like that and that's the way you know
the capitalist system works and so one
of the challenges is to figure out how
do you how do you keep doing the really
great stuff and don't you know not to
say they should that it shouldn't grow
but how does growth take place without
it then just becoming one more
successful business you know but but
again you go back to what does it
business do yeah as a business grows it
impacts its theater system right right
Miller doesn't clean Miller employees
don't clean I don't think that what I've
been there in a while but you know they
probably have somebody come in to clean
the building true they have you know
they have truckers who drive you know
who may or may not be
employed by the company who drive their
product - whether it needs to go they
have all kinds of things going on so as
a matter of fact one of the jobs I had I
was a PR manager for two of the brands
when in the last five years I was at
Miller and such ones were the Lowenbrau
and Magnum oh yes and I had to get in
the minds of both of those who I didn't
and so one of the things that I did was
I said okay they gave me a budget
shouldn't it done that because it said
okay
I looked around and I said okay now who
do I know that's got a tan that can
produce you know provide some of the
services I need yeah and so I went out
and I found people who has you know
qualifications to do the job and I
invited them in to do a presentation and
then literally after we had done the
formal business thing I closed the door
on them and I said how many times have
you been in this building to do business
oh this is my first time okay and why
are you here yeah yeah cuz you invited
me in okay don't make me say the same
thing no no no I said don't make me look
bad because if I if I'm not here you
know and and I said it in a joking way
but serious and and there was nobody
than I had to find her oh yeah he did
their thing and you know one catering
business sounds look like they were
showing up every week with food yeah and
so so given that opportunity you know to
use my resources to try to do that well
that's so that fits into it the sort of
circulation of of money that you were
talking about I don't know if all the
viewers will and we're almost a powerful
but the idea is that the more times that
the dollar exchanges hands within a
particular community it's it's
increasing the power of that dollar to
facilitate exchanges of services
definitely it doesn't actually make
anybody richer because it's still just
one dollar
and it is changing hands but it allows
people to get what they need more
efficiently right and and it actually
does increase I mean because again you
know if I have to buy flour
you got a flour mill and I buy it from
you versus Pillsbury yeah somebody in
another state I'm that's why they
they're always you know the the Small
Business Administration in particular
you know has pushed for buying local
yeah and that's why they do that it's
not just about businesses owned by
people of color it's about businesses
within a community yeah and and so that
that rule applies regardless of the
nationality of the owner of the business
the more it circulates within Milwaukee
and you're circulating you know you're
buying stuff from Milwaukee people then
those businesses will ramp up they may
not become Miller Brewing Company they
may not become Harley but they may be
hired to five or ten feet up so in the
time that we have left is there anything
else you wanted to say about your
writing
yeah projects well what the other all
the other the music really pieces I this
is my this is the tape of the opera that
I wrote and it's I'll tell the brief
story on that I again I found this
really interesting story about this
African tribal chief that had been
captured to bring over here to be
enslaved and then he managed to escape
he became a pirate and he you know
roamed around the keys for 20 years
terrorizing everything and he was so
good at what he did that I think it was
Britain and France sent their Navy over
to get him together
yeah Wow yeah so anyway I thought that
would make a good story cuz I wrote I
wrote the libretto and it took me until
the - I wrote it in 76 and it took me
until 2000 something to find a composer
and it was a guy by the name of Neil
Tate why later found out after I had you
know asked him if he would write the
music cuz I I met him through oh that's
okay well still be recording okay so I
asked him if he would you know write the
music yeah and it turns out that he was
first
like music director on Broadway and he
was living in more oh why
and then I'm working with the music the
music director at my church and we're
doing an album finishing up an album
it's called bad movie and it's basically
kind of social consciousness raising
album that kind of deals with what's
going on down well that's excellent
so what I mean it seems like you know
you there's over and over again there's
like a story well I reached out to this
person I I tried this you must be very
tenacious when it comes to finding a
place for your writings or finding
collaborators do you have any advice for
young particularly young viewers who I
think often lack that one keep asking I
mean there's somebody out there that
you're going to meet like I said I do
with black Caesar the the the opera you
know I asked some local people to write
the music and they looked at me like you
think they didn't even bother to to look
at the the words and I was like who are
you you know yeah I think you're not in
the music you know you're not gonna
music real - yeah you are
and but I didn't let that stop me I
didn't throw it away
and when I met mr. Tate through he was a
music director at the African American
children's theatre okay and I knew the
the person who was the founder of it and
I actually asked for an introduction and
he said well you know let me let take a
look at it and he did and he said let's
do it and I went how much and he said
well we'll just you know write it put
together an agreement and then you know
when we start making money we'll just
split it 50/50 you know yeah but he was
from New York so don't be afraid to ask
don't be afraid to be persistent and you
don't have to run people over and grab
them by their ties and you know drag
them down the street or anything like
that yeah but but but there's you know
if you want to do something there's
somebody out there that can have that
you can work with it and also you know
network with people I was going to ask
about that is it is it important to like
constantly be making contact sir yeah
it's it's important to make contacts to
net and and hang around when one of the
essays in my book is who you hang with
matters you know if you if you want
people if you want to move forward hang
around people who have that same mindset
hey I want to move and do this I want to
move and do that I want to you know I'm
looking for I want I don't want to I
don't want to say we're doing the same
thing and that's one of the things that
I think is not happening as much and
part of it is that I was six when the
Brown versus Board of Education really
came down and those in our generation
that's the desegregation yeah yeah a
desegregation of schools and part of it
we had three things that we knew we were
supposed to do we were supposed to take
advantage of the opportunity we were
supposed to move the football down the
field meaning don't just be happy to be
there but see how far you can you know
you know move into other opportunities
and they were to do it in a way that did
not make it difficult for people coming
up from behind us to have the same
opportunity and so and so the idea of
pushing forward yeah you know was not
strange to to me and or to our
generation and basically for me the way
I worked you know got my head around
dealing with adversity in those
circumstances was I started to see it as
a chess game after I learned how to play
chess yeah and it's like you know what
you have to do you have to figure out
what move you want to make you have to
figure out what counter moves somebody
else can make and then you see what
other options you have before you make
your move kind of thing and then you may
not capture the Queen but you may knock
out a whole bunch of other you know
pieces before before they expect I mean
do you think that younger people simply
in general I mean there's gonna be
exceptions are not getting that sort of
training they're not getting that and
they're not getting that because I think
my mother was a teacher and in a
guidance counselor in education that
they there was a tendency to educate the
whole child so they in addition to the
academic stuff you had home activities
where where kids could find a reason to
want you know to come to school besides
the fact that their parents told him to
yeah
and in a group that they can affiliate
with and like for instance my mother
started out as a home and a home act
teacher and what she would do was when
she was teaching cooking she would say
okay we're gonna bake a cake today and
then she and and oh and here's a recipe
I remember you talking about how she
introduced math math and and and so she
gave everybody a quarter cup measuring
cup and she said now we need a cup of
flour so we can have to figure out how
many of these we need to put in the bowl
to get a cup so those kinds of things so
those things are not happening as much
and part of it is not so much a matter
of teachers not trying the system is
different again we now have people who
have decided that I have the curriculum
that will save the world and they're
selling that to schools and there was a
woman I've done some volunteer work in a
MPS school there was a woman who was you
know I had worked with one he one
semester and she was rockin and rollin
and then the next next semester I came
in and she had a mini meltdown and she
said people we're not what we should be
you know I put up all the stuff and
we're not where we should be and so I
talked to her afterwards so I was it was
because of the benchmarks that she was
supposed to read he was supposed to
agree to reach certain but benchmarks
but the problem was that a month before
school opened yeah the school switched
the curricula oh so she was no longer
operating off the curriculum that she
had had
for yeah and she had to take all of that
stuff down learn the curriculum and then
put all the stuff in place so the kids
could could operate in the framework of
the new curriculum ah in a month time
that's insane yeah that's that's
practically impossible and and so to me
I mean teachers spend four years
learning how to teach so just because
this company has a box with stuff in it
doesn't mean yeah that that's going to
be better than what they can come up
with because one of the things the
teachers used to do is identify the
learning style of the child yeah and
then help them learn whatever the
subject was in that style yeah so
there's a lot less local autonomy yeah I
might have my daughter and well even my
son talks about this as well that you
know they spend so much time prepping
for standardized tests exactly and she
was very disappointed that she can't
she's told you we can't study this thing
that you'd like to study because well
that time is allocated to test prep
exactly exactly
and you don't have you have people who
may have like an inch deep of knowledge
of whatever the subject asks for the for
the test but they don't necessarily
they're not able they're not able to
integrate integrated and they don't
necessarily know how to critically think
that through so somebody says oh the
room is on fire the door is over there
but you can't leave by the door okay I
guess I'll have to die you know what as
opposed to oh heck no let me get my cell
phone I can call somebody I mean it's
not quite that bad but but but but you
know just the idea that we learned
critical thinking skills we learned you
know we had what they call world history
we had US history now of course you
didn't have the stuff annex to civics we
don't have anymore in civics you know so
that's why people don't understand that
the first words in the Constitution are
we the people and we can hire and fire
as we choose that's why they don't know
that because they're not
learning that in school you know I think
my my generation was the last to do
sentence diagramming in and then that
was considered you know to be oppressive
and we shouldn't force that on kids now
if we're teaching foreign languages of
course we still use it because it turns
out it works yeah I mean we could go on
and I think about about that well is
there anything else that you'd like to
hit on or mention or or talk about I
mean you've had a great career you're
still and you're still in it and which
is which is also something to look up to
is there anything else you'd like to
talk about you know what this has been
wonderful I didn't know where we were
going and how we were going to get there
but this has been a wonderful experience
and I think you know I've enjoyed it and
and hopefully your viewers will you know
find something of interest that that was
talked about oh I think yeah well thanks
very much for giving your time and
thanks for the opportunity
you